salve sono daniela lourdes falanga
referente alle politiche trans per
arcigay napoli presidente
dell'associazione arcigay vesuvio
rainbow
sono qui per parlarvi di una questione
sensibile molto interessante c'è un
bambino immortalato nel giorno di
carnevale da principe azzurro
esattamente come si farebbe in maniera
opposta ad una bambina da principessa
solitamente in rosa un bambino costretto
da sempre ad essere parte della fiera di
una costrizione di quella che io
definisco la una costruzione di altri il
pensiero degli altri
il desiderio di qualcosa che esiste
prima addirittura della vita di essere
conformi al solito a quello che in
questi secoli ha purtroppo condizionato
in maniera violenta la società fino a
creare gravi disagi
una questione che tocca in maniera
viscerale le persone trans cioè tutte
quelle persone che hanno il coraggio di
fare un percorso di
modifica dell'aspetto del corpo cioè
tutte quelle persone che credono che
attraverso una ridefinizione dei
perimetri corporali possano trovare e
manifestare maniera completa la propria
ragione la ragione silenziata
mortificata ma personale intima
soggettiva il corto della fantasia
la ragione il principio di tutto negata
solo perché desiderosa di avere quel
corpo con il quale agisce scusate mi
capirete anche il mio parlare lento dopo
un corpo agito desiderato in un certo
modo perché costrittivo perché lesivo
della personalità di quei momenti in cui
una persona si sente davvero in una
prigione
vediamo delle immagini
pina una persona transessuale trovata a
terra con un ictus
portata in ospedale è fatta purtroppo
assistere
da persone che hanno l'hanno denudata
completamente davanti a quattro uomini
claudia l'altra persona transessuale
trovata a terra e quasi uccisa da un
serial killer una persona che è stata
portata sempre in uno spazio in una
camera di soli uomini
ancora una volta ancora lesa il dramma
nel dramma
alessia stava in un autobus rientrava
per andare a casa
fu aggredita violentemente il conducente
dell'autobus nemmeno si girò per
chiedere cosa stesse accadendo
immaginate che questo accade nel
quotidiano anche attraverso gli sguardi
morbosi delle persone che guardano il
corpo la nostra radice il manifesto
della nostra radice il manifesto della
nostra identità che sfugge ad ogni
convenzione quindi va in qualche modo
violato silenziato
ma cosa accade nella violenza beh si
crea morte sociale silenzio si crea voto
possiamo andare avanti
alessia insieme a me
in uno di quegli eventi in cui
rivendichiamo il nostro orgoglio le
nostre necessità
la nostra normalità possiamo vedere
invece qui una rosa vi chiederete il
perché di questa rosa e la rosa braccata
nel mio giardino
in realtà ripresa due anni fa è una
delle rose più antiche al mondo
bellissima rustica forte e rampicante in
realtà vuole identificare il volto di
una persona di un ragazzo fm
c'è una femmina che diventa maschio sono
il 40 per cento delle persone che
compiono il percorso di transizione fu
rapito letteralmente dai genitori dal
luogo in cui stava a bologna insieme
alla sua ragazza portato nel vesuviano
fatto depilare completamente portato in
spiaggia con un costume a due pezzi e
purtroppo anche di fronte a due
esorcisti e ad alcuni psichiatri
terribile storia questa rosa rappresenta
semplicemente il giorno seguente la
rinascita di questa persona che avvenne
in una casa d'accoglienza che purtroppo
oggi non c'è più e di cui abbiamo
davvero necessità ed esprime la felicità
di una libertà ritrovata il viaggio a
bologna di nuove dalla sua compagna e
qui invece vedete quello che faccio il
mio lavoro il mio impegno sociale
questo foto rappresenta qualcosa di
molto importante per me
sono con il presidente di arcigay
antonello sannino e in questo momento
incontro i ragazzi lo facciamo negli
enti pubblici negli enti privati queste
sono le scuole i ragazzi che desiderano
informarsi desiderano prendere le
distanze da tutto quanto è stato
inculcato e che purtroppo ha reso in
parte c'è chi non tolleranti anche
violenti come vi ho mostrato vedete che
c'è una grande accoglienza sempre sono
di solito i ragazzi che chiedono il
nostro intervento sono i ragazzi più che
professori e dopo gli applausi gli
abbracci e tutto quanto è una stupenda
interazione e scoperta lui e fabio
ragazzo del futuro n
il pride l'evento culmine delle
associazioni lgbt una processione di
colori la momento in cui rivendichiamo
le nostre istanze
una processione politica in realtà è che
qui siamo per esprimere libertà
uguaglianza pari dignità anche gridare
felicemente le nostre identità daniela
mia nipote una bambina priva di
qualsiasi pensiero ideologico sorridente
felice qui e in un evento delle famiglie
arcobaleno è stata semplicemente
tra madri padri bambini figli di due
genitori non riconosciuti in parte sì
perché questi bambini ufficialmente
hanno solo un genitore solo perché i
loro genitori sono omosessuali
lei è felice e serena non ha visto altro
che famiglie felici e lo dimostra nel
suo sguardo nel suo sorriso soprattutto
è figlia di persone eterosessuali non ha
alcun trauma come potete vedere ancora
di nuovo quel bambino quella principe
azzurro
e un'immagine forte per me è un bambino
al quale è stato tolto la possibilità di
godersi l'infanzia l'adolescenza il
gioco una formazione sana che ha avuto
però il coraggio di riprendersi la sua
identità anche attraverso il corpo per
quella che poi ha capito essere la sua
nuova felicità grazie